how long three days
i wonderf and you're on earth hmm there
was not convinced that you would survive
the journey to ask God where's Jane
she's resting she is quite exceptional I
thought you'd been blinded by passion
but in truth you are the only one who
could see and you did what needed to be
done Loki you did the right thing
we're like the worst mistake ever what
you don't know
[Music]
you
let us begin welcome back everyone is
Charlie this is gonna be my new Avengers
infinity Saga deleted scene with Thor
becoming King Thor this is at least the
third time maybe fourth time that we've
seen him been named King in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe they keep trying to
name him King but something always goes
wrong so we'll break it down there's a
completely alternate ending that will
break down and there's a lot of this
scene that I just cut down for the
purposes of this video that I think that
they'll bring back around for Thor for
love and thunder so I'll explain the
stuff that they cut out that I think
that they'll bring back we're doing the
big infinity saga box set giveaway with
all the blu-rays for all the movies
that's where the scene came from all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite Thor deleted
scene on the video we'll just break this
down top eighth style starting with
number eight so Thor wakes up recovering
from the battle at the sight of Odin
watching over him in a more dignified
earthly form remember the other deleted
scene with him in the alleyway where he
named Thor King Thor and gave him the
odinforce so in this version of the
scene Odin is still wearing his armor
it's just that he Thor Loki all the
Asgardians that come to Planet Earth on
a regular basis laid enchantments just
basic enchantments on their armor in
their weapons to disguise them so that
they blend in with all the other regular
people Tyko really took that joke and
ran with it during thor ragnarok like
especially Thor with the version of his
hammer that was the umbrella like don't
forget your hammer as he calls it to
himself just saying sorry as it crashes
through every room in the sanctum but
he's basically sitting here telling Thor
that I didn't think that you would
survive the journey through the Bifrost
because your wounds were so bad so we
just wanted you to heal for a couple
days number seven Odin tells Thor he'd
make a very good King speaks very highly
of Jane Foster is basically telling him
he's passing the title because the test
of the early Thor movies was Thor really
wanting to be king early as thinking
that he wanted to be king in Odin
thinking he wasn't ready yet this is the
point where Odin is like you're
definitely ready I'm going to retire you
become King take the mantle there was
another part of this deleted scene that
I cut out where Jane Foster has a really
long talk with Thor about their
relationship and about how she's afraid
to go live on Asgard and be his queen
actually be queen of Asgard because as a
human she's much less advanced in the
Asgardians and she doesn't want to feel
useless up there like she's
really smart scientist on planet earth
but all the scientists living on Asgard
doing what she would be doing were she
to move to Asgard to become queen she'd
feel completely useless among them so
number six this is some of the stuff I
think they'll bring back around and
incorporate into Thor for love and
thunder when she becomes a version of
female four from the comics like the
idea that she's not completely worthless
there's a lot of questions about what's
gonna happen with the future of them as
a couple within the MCU in the future
like Thor seems like he's still in love
with her in the title of Thor 4 is love
and thunder so I think at least part of
the movies going to address that but
there's a big question about what's
going to happen with Thor after Thor for
love and thunder because it doesn't
sound like they're gonna kill him off
but Chris Hemsworth wants to come back
and do more movies so just open up a
bookmark in chrome for that status
pending for Thor after Thor for love and
thunder number 5 Darcy comes back during
this scene telling Jane Foster that she
made a big mistake to not move to Asgard
with Thor like come on we don't know
what would have happened if you'd have
moved up there pretty solid bet that's
another joke that they'll bring back
around during Thor for love and thunder
I don't know if Darcy's going to be in
that movie but we do know that she's
coming back during Avengers 1 division
Disney Plus episodes they didn't say
what she'd be doing during the events of
that series but because she's mostly a
scientist and we know they're officially
canonizing the sword organization from
the comics and clarifying that Nick
Fury's space station from the spider-man
far from home post-credit scene is the
source space station from the comics
maybe Darcy maybe Erik Selvig and Jane
Foster tangentially are all working with
sword in the events after Avengers
endgame even though a couple of those
characters like Jane Foster and Erik
Selvig we probably won't hear about till
after Thor for like they didn't say the
Erik Selvig would show up during one
division number four they also addressed
this funny tongue-in-cheek moment of
Loki making himself look like King doing
his own fake coronation ceremony parody
of the one that Thor got during the
first Thor movie that's actually part of
a whole other deleted scene - it's
basically Loki while he's still in
prison just sort of making this illusion
for himself making it seem like he's
worthy and being honored by his people
they kind of brought that joke back
around during Thor Ragnarok at the end
in the big final battle when the ship
comes in and Loki's standing on the
bridge and says my people your savior is
here number three then there
a completely different ending to Thor
the dark world where Thor goes back to a
scar before the events of thor ragnarok
pickup in officially takes the mantle of
king of Asgard from Odin becoming King
Thor this is all happening while Odin is
still alive presumably unless you
believe that this is the fake version of
Odin and Loki has been masquerading as
him during this entire deleted scene in
this deleted scene ending is the
complete opposite he goes back to Asgard
with Odin takes the mantle and
officially becomes King Thor it's funny
how many times they've tried to turn him
into King Thor in these movies but
obviously they completely changed the
paradigm because if you remember after
Thor the dark world when they were
heading into Avengers infinity war
Avengers endgame Chris Hemsworth's
contract was going to be up after
Avengers endgame he said he got really
tired with playing the character he
didn't like this version of Thor from
for the dark world he does he just
gotten really bored with what they were
doing with the character it wasn't until
for Ragnarok came around that Taika
Waititi pitched a completely different
version of Thor they completely changed
the character in Kevin Feige even said
that thor ragnarok was kind of like the
beginning of a new trilogy of Thor
movies even though I don't know that
they're gonna do Thor 5 or anything like
that
Chris Hemsworth is saying that he wants
to do more Thor but I think when they
say more Thor it'll be him coming back
during future huge crossover movies
future Avengers movies like Avengers 5
number 2 there's still a lot of
questions about how tyka is going to
handle the story of Thor for love and
thunder because a lot of these
characters and things will come back
around like I said bringing some of the
deleted scene moments into Thor for love
and thunder and addressing it during
that movie Thor still traveling around
with the guardians of the galaxy as
guardians of the galaxy style probably
using Star Wars Bowflex to lose all that
weight he's still worthy of the hammer
so if they're gonna do this story of
female Thor there's still the question
of which hammer she uses because hella
smashed the hammer during thor ragnarok
in thor technically is still worthy
because we saw him wilting his hammer
from Thor the dark world during avengers
endgame there's also still the question
of the alternate version of Loki who's
currently running around being chased
down through the multiverse by the time
variants authority and it would be weird
to have a Thor movie without Loki in it
so number 1 WTF early theory because you
have to involve this alternate version
of Loki
an easy way to include him and solve
some of your continuity problems and
plot problems with the alternate version
of the hammer you could just have him
cross paths with Thor while he's trying
to escape the time variance Authority
and through Loki's actions an alternate
version of Mjolnir comes from an
alternate reality or an alternate placed
in the timeline that can be the one that
Jane Foster wields just because I think
it'd be kind of boring to just reforge
the old version of mill near that was
smashed and you have to have a version
of that in order to explain female Thor
Jane Foster that doesn't really address
what the main villain has to do with any
of it because they'll probably be part
of the reason for the sequence of events
that leads to Jane Foster becoming
worthy of the hammer Christian Bale is
rumored to be playing an intergalactic
villain everyone has a ton of theories
about that but I think Marvel still
trying to lock him down under contract
so he hasn't officially been cast in
Thor for love and thunder yet but
everyone post all your reactions and
theories in the comments do you like
this deleted scene of Thor becoming King
Thor better than the original one and
what do you think Nick Fury and sword
are doing during the events of one
division because even though Nick Fury
won't be on one division the sword
organization will be part of one
division I've done videos for a bunch of
other Avengers infinity saga deleted
scenes you can click here to watch all
those and you can click here for that
brand-new spider-man 4 special marble
announcement video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight